de retour dans l'ancien studio pour le
week-end bien évidemment je me suis posé
une question au sujet de ces petites
bêtes lorsque j'ai parlé à quelques mois
des rumeurs sur l'iphone 11 sur ce qui
pouvait devenir
eh bien on parlait déjà de cette espèce
de caméras comme ça et moi je trouve ça
assez moche en fait très moche
d'ailleurs et je me suis dit apple ne
fait surtout pas ça c'est une très
mauvaise idée
le temps passant les produits sont
présentés et au final lorsque je les ai
vus à la présentation je me suis dit
c'est mieux intégré que ce que je
pensais c'est moins moche que que ce que
je pensais au final est ce que c'est une
bonne idée de la part d'apple depuis
longtemps comment est en fait le truc
le truc vraiment c est ce qu au final
apple fait les bons choix est-ce qu'au
final apple est pas en train devenir une
marque vient en retard au niveau de ses
produits de cisco niveau du design
est ce qu'apple ne devient pas une
marque has been sur les iphone c'est ce
qu'on va voir et vous allez voir il ya
plein de choses à raconter
[Musique]
non
petit aparté pour un très important je
sais pas si vous avez fait gaffe j'ai
commencé à activer le bouton rejoindre
et justement pour ceux qui sont aux
paliers numéro 2 vous allez pouvoir
voter me dire quels tests vous voulez
prochainement qu'elle sera lé prochain
texte c'est à vous de choisir sa vous
nous dire quels tests vous voulez alors
voyez par exemple on a ici 2009 light de
chiens oui on a aussi le samsung galaxy
et 80 où j'ai pas testé qui est là on va
se tester toujours c'est beaucoup ça me
sont là on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de produits samsung galaxy tab est sis à
tester donc ce sera vous de me dire ce
que vous voulez le note 10 de samsung on
va sortir le test aussi il est pressé
mais il faut juste me dire que c'est ce
qu'on sort et puis un produit
exceptionnel je suis très heureux le
galaxy fold on en reparlera
prochainement à me dire lequel produit
vous voulez en premier lequel vous
voulez qu'on paie son premier ace
conteste ces produits-là s conteste ces
deux iphone en premier boire beauté
c'est facile mais suffit de cliquer sur
le bouton rejoindre de devenir membre de
la team greu le deuxième palier à 99 pas
moi dans ta pouvaient voter et vous
prenez les commandes de la chaîne on
parle plus des iphone par rapport à leur
esthétique aujourd'hui par rapport au
fait d'avoir ce triple module caméra là
et ce double module caméra là plutôt que
aux iphones qui sont capables de faire
par rapport à la performance je suis
persuadé qu'apple est énorme au point de
vue software ils ont une force de frappe
au niveau de l'intégration au niveau
d'un écosystème global qui communiquent
ensemble macbook l'univers un macbook
lille d'armagh globale les appels watch
bien évidemment les iphone et tutti
quanti en plus avec l'arrivée d'apple
arcadiens peuls musique et tous les
services d'apple que ce soit le
streaming tenais compagnie apple un
écosystème qui est extrêmement puissant
extrêmement performant je pense que la
partie logicielle la partie solution la
partie abonnement va permettre à apple
en train de se développer davantage et à
récupérer un petit peu le retard qu'ils
ont autre cas du du point de vue
de la vidéo en vod notamment par rapport
à netflix c'est une certitude mais bon
voilà il ya plein de choses à faire de
ce côté là et je me dis est ce qu'au
final ils seront pas fait les mauvais
choix est-ce que ça c'est une bonne idée
eh bien mon avis c'est pas une si
mauvaise idée que ça ce que je propose
c'est qu'on regarde ça on va les mettre
tout nu on va et déshabiller on va les
effeuiller les zones boxer en garde
cycling est ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire j'ai donc reçu de
nouveaux iphone celui là le premier
produit 13 que je trouve très jolie que
j'aime beaucoup
on est effectivement vous l'avez juste
là on est sur l'iphone 11 l'iphone onze
de base qui est la base mais qu'elle a
une très très très jolie base d'un point
de vue technique en tout cas et puis on
a celui là on a le 11 promax le grand
modèle de très grands modèles le full
option celui qui a 500 12 giga octet et
non pas de gigabyte de ram il est là est
beau il est chaud il est sympa on va
commencer par ouvrir l'iphone 11 pour
voir un petit peu c'est à dire je pense
que de toute façon
d'un point de vue boxing ça va être à
peu près à mi-chemin toujours il façon
très facile très simple d'ouvrir
toujours un côté très sympa là on a un
relief là on a le relief je le sens où
le bois qui est rigolo juste au niveau
du module photo on a le relief aussi au
niveau de l'appareil au niveau du logo
ya rien bien travaillé bien packagée
bien dessinés toujours bien fait et
cette fois ci quand vous l'ouvrez il se
présente par l'arrière l'innovation et
là la nouveauté là parce que 5 du point
de vue de la face avant quand vous le
regardez comme c'est en tout cas il n'y
a pas grande innovation n'y a pas de
grandes nouveautés on essaie en tout qui
marche mais bon voilà il n'ya pas des t
notes de feuilles
là par contre vous arrivez avec ce
module caméra vous aimez ou vous n'aimez
pas c'est un peu le débat aujourd'hui on
ouvre on effeuille on le met tout nu
voilà sympa yoplait à la protection
avant qu'ils aient enlevé sur les côtés
cette année il n'y a pas de protection
là de pas mal plus tôt plutôt original
pourquoi pas prise en main je trouve un
peu large et l'habitude d'avoir des
smartphones un peu plus fin un poil
lâche pour venir chercher aux métaphores
utilisées à demain bon c'est vraiment du
pain de détails d'une pomme qui beaucoup
plus gros ça c'est assez surprenant
vraiment d'avoir fait c'est une grosse
grosse pomme mais bon pourquoi pas c'est
marrant parce que j'ai l'impression de
fait d'avoir cette grosse pomme en
termes de proportion par rapport au
modèle j'ai l'impression qu'en fait il
est petit il est plus petit c'est une
association effectivement un peu plus
réduite c'est assez marrant
est ce que c'est un choix j'imagine par
rapport aux modules photos que certaines
îles scilly très probablement vous avez
si la petite notion
retraite parce que c'est un produit le
trade il ya de l'argent qui va vers sa
lutte contre le comprend le sida bon
après à l'intérieur on retrouve un peu
quand même des grands classiques et le
design by apple on va voir les infos sur
red bien évidemment on va avoir les
petits logos on va voir découvrir le
terroir de cartes sim voir toutes les
informations sur votre iphone en fin de
formation un petit peu sommaire ensuite
à l'intérieur ben quoi rien rien de bien
extraordinaire de franquevaux petits
écouteurs vous allez pouvoir venir
collecter ici directement avec votre
portable lightning juste là vous avez
votre câble lightning usb vous avez
votre chargeur en usb qui est un petit
peu standard mais qui marche là y'a rien
de bien bien dans cette boîte fois la
petite des couples été fait c'était
vraiment pensé pour être l'un vertes on
ne pas venir habiller cette partie là ça
vient s'emboîter directement là dedans
pourquoi pas c'est rigolo les finitions
sont sympa en tout cas toujours sympa on
arrive maintenant sur le grand modèle 11
promax très grands modèles alors pareil
on a effectivement ce côté relief ici
belle finition très sympa voilà ça cesse
à ses côtés un peu cali d'apple et xing
est toujours très très très sympa bien
soigné on arrive bien évidemment voyez
votre choix petit module ici la place
conjointe d'une photo ils arrivent ils à
l'envers alors pour cette couleur là
c'est un petit peu un petit peu plus
doux on le voit un peu moins d quand je
le mets comme ça le fait de faire
ressortir le logo logo toujours plus
gros plus omniprésent le côté c'est eux
je sais pas si vous le voyez là là vous
avez la norme c'est eux qui est beaucoup
plus discrète même sur sur l'autre c'est
discret ça se voit beaucoup moins
pourtant elle est là c'est une
obligation légale elle est présente on
va l'ouvrir exactement de la même
manière de la même manière on n'a
absolument rien à enlever sur le côté
why not je le trouve une fois de plus un
pelage
après c'est pas un problème il faut
juste savoir ce smartphone vous avez
utilisé à demain parce qu'ils sont venus
chercher ici une seulement vous pouvez
le faire mais bon faut pas risquer de de
faire tomber d'ailleurs au vampire
quelques instants de protection c'est
très important
moi je trouve surprenant je trouve
différents différenciant sur l'excellent
terme mais je trouve pas moche je vous
expliquer pourquoi à l'intérieur de la
boîte on va avoir la même chose les
petites doc on va avoir vos écouteurs et
là où ça change c'est qu'ici vous avez
de la connectique en usb c'est on arrive
à la gamme pro à la gamme pro maintenant
voyez on est les ipad procès du sbc les
macbook pro toute la connectique est un
usb c'est hélas vous arrivez vous avez
de la connectique en usb c'est soit
qu'il ya une vraie volonté de la part
d'apple de différencier la gamme un peu
standard qui est
très bien et la gamme professionnelle
avec ses connectiques en usb c'est la
fin de l'usb un peu standard pour
pouvoir se pensent mieux connecté entre
les différents au duc soit votre macbook
pro que ce soit votre ipad c'était donc
l'idée en tout cas là dessus et je la
trouve plutôt bonne vous avez quand même
pour un peu cher de ses smartphones donc
très important de les protéger alors
bien évidemment je vais vous parler des
[ __ ] aussi parce que j'ai un
partenariat avec rhinochill sous le
savez c'est pas nouveau mais c'est très
très important d'un point de vue global
extrêmement important parce que même si
vous avez un verre qui est sécurisé même
si vous avez un produit de qualité mais
c'est pas infaillible il peut tomber il
peut mal tombé il peut se casser ils
peuvent endommager et vu le prix du
produit
parce que franchement d'être je ne peux
donc que vous recommander de prendre des
coques de protection alors il existe
plusieurs solutions chez rhinochill et
moi j'aime bien ce système parce que je
trouve bien vous allez avoir la coque de
base par exemple pour celui là vous
prenez vous mettez votre coque vous
lacéré dedans et ça marche ça vous le
protège au moins quand il est à plat il
est vraiment un plat il est pas en train
de bouger de tous les côtés et moins
vous avez un truc et sécurisé vous allez
avoir les crasses garde enix alors ça
c'est assez intéressant parce qu'en fait
pour vous dire que vous n'avez pas
forcément envie que votre iphone vous ne
voyez pas le dos il est déjà un joli dos
je veux le protéger mais je vais le voir
c'est quand même dommage de ne pas le
montrer
et je vous comprends parce que
franchement c'est vrai qu'il est
chouette et bien vous utilisez ça vous
le prenez vous venez de mettre dedans
vous le mettez up à sa petite taille
vous l'installez tranquillement et là
l'intéressé qui va être complètement
protégé vous allez pouvoir le poser à
plat sans que ça bouge sans que ça règle
si vous êtes tranquille mais vous
profiter quand même d'un dock est assez
sympa donc ça c'est vrai que c'est une
protection qui est pas mal après ce que
je vous conseille quand même c'est de
protéger votre écran parce que si jamais
prend un choc bien vous avez des
protections d'écran qui marche bien pour
toutes les tailles et ça à mon avis est
vraiment hyper important et comme dirait
l'autre sortez couverts ça encore plus
de sens parce que là il ya un modèle qui
est là pour lutter contre le sida donc
sortez couverts de tous les côtés pour
lutter contre le sida et sortez couverts
protégeant votre smartphone donc ça
c'est plutôt cool comme je le disais moi
que tu es vachement posé de questions
sur ce produit je me suis dit est-ce
qu'au final le fait
de travail et un design comme ça c'est
une erreur est ce que c'est une connerie
on va dire les termes commission au
final est-ce que c'est plutôt une bonne
idée et est-ce que c'est plutôt au final
l'idée révolutionnaire parce que très
clairement une boîte comme apple il faut
beaucoup de recherche et développement
ils passent beaucoup de temps pour
sortir un produit et au final quand le
produit à sortir ils vont pas vous
proposer un truc n'a fait à la va-vite
pas pensé pas réfléchi et pas du tout
adapté au marché
donc est ce que au final ce design là
vous trouvez un peu bizarre et vous vous
dites c'est une plaque de cuisson ou je
sais pas quoi
parce qu'en fait c'est que notre oeil
est pas habitué et que au final c'est
l'idée et c'est justement le bon design
et qu'apple a misé sur le bon design ou
alors est-ce qu'au final apple se plante
complètement et est ce que le fait de
proposer des choses comme ça ça ne
montre qu'ils sont plus du tout dans
l'air du temps qui sont plus dans le
coup et qui savent plus faire des
smartphones en tout cas d'un point de
vue esthétique c'est la bonne question
alors il ya au au quand je vous dis que
c'est important de les protéger je ne
plaisante pas un mais moi je me suis dit
des fois pas doué mais là tout va bien
donc pour les besoins de la vidéo j'ai
pas mis la coque de production
uniquement pour montrer un joli
smartphone et une fois que je vais
sortir je vais le protège et croyez moi
parce que je vais devoir le tester bien
évidemment donc jettera plein de photos
je dormais avec moi je vais donc le
protéger et je vous invite vous à faire
exactement la même chose d'ailleurs si
ça vous intéresse vous avez 10 % de
remise avec le code monsieur dreux vous
avez un lien en bas d'un description
aller jeter un coup d'oeil je vous
assure ça pourra franchement vous sauver
la vie
la preuve une fois de plus un smartphone
ça glisse fera quand même relativement
d'un lot de le casser et surtout vu le
prix je vous dis donc qu'est un autre
point qui est aussi très important c'est
cette question de l'encoche et ça c'est
le point qui m'a le plus embêté qui va
le plus perturbé je me suis dit pour la
troisième année à peu revient avec une
encoche face et 3e ou des en tout cas
avec cette grande encoches intégrant
fayçal dit alors a failli saïdi toujours
plus rapide toujours plus performants
avec un meilleur angle pour
déverrouiller rapidement pourquoi pas
les technos ont amélioré les technos ont
optimisé mais si vous regardez par
rapport à ce qui à la concurrence je
vais vous prendre par exemple ce que je
vais avoir dans le coin là où one + 7
pro eh bien regardez vous avez tout
simplement un grand écran sans encoches
donc une grande surface utilisable
vous n'avez donc absolument aucune
pollution lorsque vous allez regarder
une série un film tandis que vous
ce que vous allez utiliser votre iphone
même si là je n'ai pas encore allumé et
bien vous savez que vous avez l'encoche
sur l'eau et ça c'est ça c'est
problématique parce que pour moi
visuellement il ya une pollution et
c'est en étant alors il ya deux choses
là sur la face avant
la première chose c'est que apple ne
veut pas jouer la surenchère de la
divette se réinvente en permanence la
surenchère de la techno pour de la
techno ils veulent pas dire on va
changer complètement de ce système avec
une caméra pop on va mettre une caméra
sous l'écran un fail saïdi sous l'écran
ils le feront pas tout de suite très
clairement ils le font pas parce que ce
qu'ils veulent faire en fait apple c'est
que lorsqu'ils sortent quelque chose
mais bien que ce soit complètement
parfaitement bien intégrés et maîtriser
parce que la techno il va rester
longtemps
et d'ailleurs les cas aujourd hui de
l'anc au tchad fayçali donc je pense que
là il la prochaine étape pour apple
ça va être de vous m et quand ça
arrivera quand ça sera bien en place et
prouver chez les autres ce sera donc
bien intégré ici ça avec tout simplement
un fait saïdi sous l'écran dès lors que
c'est possible techniquement un fait ça
il dit sous l'écran invisible pour vous
et un seul même et grand écran dites
vous bien que si apple pouvait le faire
ils le feraient c'était aussi évident
aujourd'hui ça serait déjà là ils
veulent pas se dire nouveau reculé sur
l'iphone on veut en vendre moins on veut
se mettre en difficulté ils ont
conscience qu'en face sur android ça
pulse énormément ils le voient à présent
une force c'est qu'ils ont leurs os
propriétaire et du fait qu'on vous
arrivez dans l'écosystème apple vous
allez potentiellement il restait donc ça
c'est vraiment leur grande force donc je
pense que pour l'instant les ivan mollo
il travaille déjà devant les proto
peut-être les modèles déjà quasiment
terminée mais pas forcément hyper bien
intégrés se sont pas forcément tout de
suite satisfait pour ne pas sortir mais
je pense que là la prochaine étape pour
apple c'est très clairement supprimer
cette encoches ça prendra du temps
ça peut prendre des années mais ça
arrivera donc ça c'est vraiment le
premier point fois coûté en tout cas de
la face avant après veut pas dire que
les écrans sont pas améliorées ça veut
pas dire qu'à part encore plus de
filtres pour réduire la lumière bleue
qui encore plus de luminosité lorsque
vous êtes en extérieur il ya beaucoup
d'innovations mais c'est vrai que
lorsque vous prenez vous le regardez
comme ça vous dit what the fuck c'est la
même chose alors qu'en fait
techniquement non pas exactement mais
par contre c'est vrai qu'ils se
ressemblent 25 tout de suite
à chaud on se dit armes c'est quoi ce
truc
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ou pas c'est
le premier truc et ensuite vous avez la
question du dos est là pour moi ils ont
quand même bossé a cherché à proposer
autre chose une autre alternative
ils sont dit ok on va faire ça ça c'est
nouveau
c'est novateur et ça c'est une prise de
risque et ça je trouve ça intéressant je
salue en tout cas apple pour la prise de
risques parce que il faut le faire c'est
connu et croyez moi qu'avec un marché
qui est en constante innovation c'est
pas toujours évident le fait de se dire
ah l'été on va bosser on va réinventer
un peu graphismes on va agrandir la
pomme va faire ça on va donc des centres
et on va donc prêt à tout casser
asymétrique assez bizarre pourquoi pas
moi je pense que en fait aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez ça et que vous vous
dites c'est moche c'est parce que votre
n'y est pas habitué
votre oeil il n'est pas fait il ya plein
de smartphones condé des nouveaux design
sont arrivés on a fait c'est quoi ce
truc c'est hyper moche et puis quelques
mois après une autre oeil s'habituer à
fait ok c'est pas mal ça me va en fait
qu'apple c'est ce qui fait la boîte sait
où elle va et je pense pas qu'il y ait
de grosses fautes de goût là dessus on
aime on n'aime pas voilà mais vous savez
il ya beaucoup de choses quand elles
sont nouvelles
on les aime pas et puis aux fins de
temps du temps on finit par s'habituer
et on finit par les aimer puis part pour
vous regarder après les modèles que vous
aviez avant voulais trouver un petit peu
ringard et un peu désuet par rapport à
ce que vous avez actuellement et je
pense que c'est justement ça un design
on pousse un autre c'est vrai pour
beaucoup de choses et c'est également
vrai pour le smartphone donc au final je
sais pas je suis pas capable aujourd'hui
de vous dire est ce que c'est le vrai
bon choix est ce que apple a fait la
vraie bonne stratégie de l'intégrer ça
comme ça c'est gros ronds noirs là
dessus est-ce que c'est vachement bien
fait je sais pas en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que je trouve ça mieux intégré
que ce que les rumeurs de proposer
pourquoi nous faisait croire il ya
quelques temps avec un espèce de faute
ou noir autour qui était assez vilain au
final c'est un espèce de seul et même
bloc
il ya un beau travail qui a été fait en
termes de recherche d'intégration le
fait d'avoir deux systèmes de verre un
petit peu différent je trouve ça assez
bien fait il ya un travail esthétique on
aime ou on n'aime pas seul le temps est
capable de nous dire c'était une bonne
idée ou une mauvaise idée a vous de me
dire ce que vous pensez par rapport à
toutes ces réflexions comment vous les
trouverez les iphone de 2019 et scoops
les trouvais intéressant est ce que vous
trouvez la promesse intéressante
est-ce que vous pensez que ce sont des
belles réussites d'ici quelques temps
j'ai publié mon test
ça nous permettra donc de savoir
réellement ce qu'ils ont dans le ventre
de voir toutes les optimisations qui va
y avoir au niveau de la photo j'ai déjà
vu un petit peu tourné sur le modèle de
quentin et je trouve assez intéressant
je pense que d'un point de vue logiciel
c'est une petite bombe atomique
je n'en doute pas un instant à peu les
ex
vraiment fort soit la partie software à
mon avis c'est là que petit bijou brésil
a vous de me dire maintenant d'un point
de vue purement esthétique comment vous
les trouvez est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une bonne idée est ce que vous
êtes d'accord sur le fait que je dire
allez les design change design évolue on
n'est pas habitué des rôles sera plus
tard ou est-ce que vous pensez que
fondamentalement c'est vraiment un gros
bull sitting très mauvaise idée a vous
de me dire tout ça en bas en commentaire
et donne rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer à parler de teck
vous allez voir j'ai eu une belle
surprise pour vous